mr. clown here for your amusement all
cultures have really celebrated the
figure of the gesture something to laugh
at
laughter is a universal concept in
decline across all languages and
cultures any of you with your Universal
methodology flamboyant gestures verging
into the ridiculous
have managed to penetrate these cultural
lines and everyone in this room can
appreciate your opera see who's
stressful the dynamic thoughts that are
occurring in my head so I have to kind
of carve compartmentalize and order
everything in a way that may not always
make sense that people listen statutes
eat them okay everybody right right
right
what about Simon Seto register the class
in Italian with Jordan and I learned the
most important phrase creepy day in the
academia of zeal and so foreign
pronouncing everything perfectly we are
here because I wish to learn to draw
again well I'm taking an art class here
in Florence the center of the
Renaissance and will male models nude
male models I'm proud to contribute to
be a male model stumpy well a tricky
term I am a male model in the United
States
[Music]
well then your body will just nice this
is my friend George
oh I thought you said are you Linda
Fiorentino you're from Florence
ciao ragazzi siamo qui EpiPens a I'm
yellow Manjot the multiband get it
sheriff you got man Punjab to lobby
state gun because it's gotta be weird
Viareggio say town by the sea they have
a Mardi Gras Festival we're gonna check
it out Carnivale eh eh oh and there's a
woman's choice not a place that I would
have gone stir so happy to slug
something you want hero and when Stanley
thinks I would enjoy it's just amazing
fans
[Music]
you